a soccer player in the Premier League
was viciously attacked by a fan last
week before later scoring a game-winning
goal this happened in a big game between
Aston Villa and Birmingham the man's
name Jack gray lish I believe was just
like knocked out from behind yeah I I
love that because I just think that
people talk about how crazy Americans
are and like Americans like oh you guys
are shooting up schools
you guys have mass shootings everyone's
nuts everyone's trying to be an
Instagram model you guys are crazy crazy
people know Europeans are crazier who
else runs on the field to punch a player
on the opposing team like maybe in
America we get naked one on the field
and it's like a funny thing you don't go
after the players ever Monica Seles that
wasn't in America remember where was
that that was that was in Europe that
was in Europe Europeans are crazy
soccer fans you're crazy you're putting
it over the hole I was just impressed it
was kind of like an older guy and like
one of those little like newsy newsboy
hats like in a kind of like a
respectable it was a madcap it was an d
cap and it was exactly the kind of
person I would do it he took him out
he looked him up I liked that I watched
the little clips of it and the coverage
of it was really funny though there was
one clip that really made me laugh of
just like their response to it in the
ninth minute a fan ran onto the pitch
and assaulted Aston Villa's Jack
greenish these are images that will stun
the world of football and without
question lead to a football association
investigation a scene that utterly
shames English football I love it I love
it I don't think they should be I don't
think you should be ashamed I mean like
it was like kind of an amazing like if
that would that was his goal right he
got a hunt you know he got an A+ if his
whole point was to like run on to the
pitch look at that and like knock the
guy out like like he got it done yeah
the guy ended up scoring late listen
English football fans are all about
dignity and carrying that dignity with
them always
if they're gonna throw a banana at an
African player with dignity if they're
gonna throw a flare at a referee's head
with dignity if they are going to riot
and fight each other because they like
different teams none of which I could
name with dignity you don't just go
runnin on the field and and take a great
shame great shame shame on you shame on
you England shame on you
soccer I'm yeah I called it soccer I
don't even know what the pitch is
it's a baseball thing Russell Westbrook
my man made national news on Monday
night in Utah it's had a history with
these this fan base I heard something he
didn't like before you get to before you
get to be at the end this let me just
say that there have been things of like
players yelling at fans fans yelling at
players this is the best thing any
player has ever yelled at a fan I wish
we could play the whole clip but the
sound quality just isn't quite good
enough but essentially this fan said
something Russell Westbrook didn't like
and he said to him I promise you you
think I'm playing I swear to God I swear
to god I'll you up you and your
wife oh you I mean listen any NBA
player I'm sure I don't know what was
said it's Russell Westbrook I'm sure the
information is out there we just did not
do our research
but he said Russell Westbrook said he's
the the fan made some comment about
getting on his knees like he used to
which I'm not even sure exactly what
that means but it's not good it's not
good it's not good and Russell Westbrook
is seems quick to anger but to
immediately had to tell someone that
they are going to them up and their
wife like it's not enough I beat you up
I want to kick your wife's ass too
I'm sure she must've been sitting next
to him at the game yes or he saw a
wedding ring and knew that he was
married is the funniest thing you could
say the funniest thing but but here's
the thing like his teammates really
defended Westbrook and Westbrook said he
doesn't take anything
back he's been hearing it from these
racist Utah fans for a long time and the
his teammates and Westbrook have a good
point that like there's so many things
protecting fans and fans right that they
can say anything and the players are
just supposed to to take it like
remember when one guy got kicked out of
the game for like he was in the front
row and he gave just like sit up and
screamed you and gave double-double
yards to Westbrook
Westbrook didn't get mad like he just
like pointing that looked at the ref and
pointed the guy I mean like is he
allowed to do that and they threw the
guy out like Russell Westbrook is can be
a hothead but he doesn't lose it every
time if someone yells something he's not
James Dolan
no and crazy and I think there was some
which is what makes us so much funnier
well any I think there was some he
thought it was some racial component and
then you look at this
this guy's Twitter account and this
guy's pretending like he didn't say
anything and that he was fine and if you
look at his Twitter account like you can
find old tweets where there was one that
said like Russell Westbrook needs to go
back where he came from hashtag mega oh
yeah and yet and yet when he was talking
to a local reporter this is the fan who
has since been banned from the stadium
friend so that's good talking to a
reporter after the game like this this
is what he sounded like when he was
talking about his wife he's got to be a
professional I mean the most in that
clip is the reporter you don't need to
go try to like laugh and support his
point in that moment you know what I
mean the reporter doesn't need to be
like hey I want to show you and the
audience I'm on your side in that moment
give me a break
I think that the fan and his wife should
have to fight Russell Westbrook I think
that would be I think that would be
great but again I think I'm gonna this
is my new go-to thing from now on if I'm
mad at someone even if they're not with
their wife I'm gonna yell you up
and your wife it just it just adds an
extra layer that that that makes me
maybe one of the best insults since I
hope your children forget how to read
I think is one of my favorite insults
all time but this is definitely up there
I want like a t-shirt I'll you up
and your wife you don't want the t-shirt
you don't people to see it coming you
want it to be a surprise when you bring
their wife into it you're like it's this
guy gonna me up oh my god a my wife
[Music]
you